wir haben gerade schon gehört die kritik
an den subunternehmern mein kollege
michael engelberg steht jetzt mit dem
sprecher von tennis andré viele städte
vor ort ja guten abend richtig nämlich
steht töne sprecher dr viele städte dr
viele städte
sie haben mitbekommen dass es extrem
unmut gibt unter anderem die dame aus
gütersloh die die insel usedom verlassen
musste weil sie halt ein nummernschild
mit gt hat wie reagieren sie als
unternehmenssprecher da drauf und ist
das nicht auch wirklich richtig bitter
für den konzern und für den ganzen kreis
ich kann natürlich erst mal die wut
dieser dame und auch der bevölkerung
kreis gütersloh sehr gut nachvollziehen
muss aber auch dazu sagen dass es für
diese abweisung der urlauberinnen ja
erst mal keine grundlage gibt
ich glaube der ministerpräsident des
landes nordrhein westfalen hat heute
sehr sehr klare worte dazu gefunden dass
es keine stigmatisierung der
gütersloherin und gütersloher geben darf
und es darf auch keine stigmatisierung
der beschäftigen in unserem unternehmen
geben wir müssen jetzt diese pandemie in
den griff bekommen pandemie ist nicht
einfach zu händeln
unabhängig davon wie groß der ausbruch
ist das ist eine mammutaufgabe
wir tun alles zusammen jetzt mit den
behörden und den wissenschaftlern um das
hinzubekommen
denn jetzt möchte alles tun wir haben
herrn dr viele städte im vorfeld dieses
gesprächs eine kurze sequenz eingespielt
wir waren heute mittag in gütersloh
unterwegs und haben mit einem
mitarbeiter eines döner imbisses
gesprochen das würden wir jetzt mal eben
ein spielen und danach mit dr
vielstedter darüber nochmal ins gespräch
kommen vorwurf mache ich den herren
tennis
aus dem grund weil er diese ganzen
rumänen die hugo hin holt mit
wasserverhältnisse die ihr leben ist
ganz schlimm
also ich kenne sehr viele roman ich
kenne bestimmt 50 prozent der rumänin
güterzügen umkreis sind alles unsere
kunden kann ich jetzt auch st wie die
leben ist die reinste katastrophe wir
haben absolut keine schuld ja die kommen
aus armen verhältnissen und versuchen
hier müssten geld zu verdienen
dabei werden wir nur verarscht ich meine
die verdienen jetzt sage ich mal
1000 1200 maximal müssten pro bett 250
euro bezahlen
ok und da arbeiten die nicht nur acht
stunden arbeiten 19 stunden und werden
nur 48 stunden bezahlen und da kommt die
hähne sind fix und fertig fix und fertig
von der arbeit wir haben nur sonntags
frei ist kein zustand
ich habe auch sehr viele rumänen die
letztes jahr wieder zurückgegangen sind
die haben gesagt wir haben gar keine
lust mehr wir können nicht mehr wir sind
fix und fertig mit so vielen menschen
eine wohnung zu leben das kann man
psychisch nicht verarbeiten
dann sind sie einfach zurück nach
rumänien nicht fertig herr doktor vier
städte sie haben den ton im vorfeld
gehört und gesehen in der man beklagt
noch mal als unternehmer also als als
jemand der ein laden besitzt das ihnen
ganz viel zurück gespielt wird welche
verhältnisse unter den mitarbeitern
herrschen was können sie ihn darauf
antworten die situation für die
unternehmer jener region ist natürlich
ganz besondere auf der einen seite sind
wir ein großer wirtschaftsfaktor
wir sind einer der größten arbeitgeber
in der region und dementsprechend auch
für die gastronomie für die
handwerksbetriebe ein wichtiger faktor
die vorwürfe die er an der stelle macht
muss ich ganz klar zurückweisen
denn das ist auch falsch keiner unserer
vollzeitbeschäftigten verdient 1000 euro
3200 euro
das wäre ein widerspruch zu
mindestlohngesetz das gibt es nicht und
es für einen vollzeitbeschäftigten
unmöglich wir sind aber auch heute mit
unserem papier und dem ersten papier für
die zukunft der arbeit
dass wir in unserer geschäftsführung dem
vorstand beschlossen haben nach vorne
gegangen
die geschäftsführung hatte entschieden
dass spätestens zum 1.1.2011 21 wir in
allen bereichen der fleischgewinnung auf
werkverträge zu verzichten werden und
dabei geht es uns vor allem darum die
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz für
fleischproduktion und für die gewinnung
von lebensmitteln in deutschland zu
behalten
wir spüren natürlich sehr viel gegenwind
aber wir spüren auch den rückenwind dass
wir lebensmittel in deutschland gewinnen
wollen
das können wir aber nur wenn wir auf der
einen seite die pandemie im griff haben
und auf der anderen seite
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz haben die
bevölkerung die politik muss wieder wir
müssen uns das vertrauen hier wieder
zurück erarbeiten damit wir diese
produktion wieder auf den in den griff
bekommen können und das ist natürlich
eine große aufgabe vertrauen
zurückgewinnen wenn man sich hier mit
leuten im kreis gütersloh unterhält
jetzt auch im kreise warendorf ist das
wirklich wirklich sehr sehr schwierig
herr dr featurette eine letzte frage mit
der mit der bitte um kurze antwort geben
sie uns einen kurzen einblick hinter
dieser tür da kommen wir alle nicht rein
wie ist wirklich die stimmung gerade das
muss sie doch auch ganz wirklich von
unten wirklich richtig anfassen was hier
gerade passiert
tatsächlich sind da nicht mehr viel drin
wir haben eine arbeits quarantäne für
wenige mitarbeiter
aber wir spüren einen sehr sehr großen
teamgeist denn sie sozusagen unser team
turniers wie wir uns selber bezeichnen
identifiziert sich sehr stark mit dem
unternehmen und wir gemeinsam das
bekenntnis dass wir diese krise
bewerkstelligen wollen und dass wir die
das vertrauen zurückgewinnen wollen wie
gesagt das wird eine mammut aufgabe sein
wenn man hier durch die stadt geht durch
den kreis wenn man mit dem landrat
spricht muss da wirklich eine ganze
menge an vertrauen zurückgewonnen werden
und es wird nicht mit losen
versprechungen funktionieren es müssen
fakten geschaffen werden
und die werden wir untersuchen
analysieren und werden uns dann wieder
melden wenn es neuigkeiten gibt